on va jouer à la tarte au trésor c'est
très simple on a envoyé deux
chroniqueurs dans les soupes dans les
souks de marrakech
regardez ils sont là puis son bord mal à
cacher dans la nature le premier des
deux chroniqueurs qui la trouve doit la
prendre et à l'ailé crâne et au visage
de son concurrent ah ouais vous allez
avoir une minute pour trouver la tarte
d'accord ok ça marche cyril est ce que
vous pouvez animer ce jeu à leurs gardes
en vient on à thibault en ligne thibault
oui un thibaut s'allumant thibault tu
nous appelles doux de compiègne d'accord
tu fais quoi dans la vie thibault je
transporte le des personnes à mobilité
réduite
très bien chérie dis moi tu es marié tu
veux fiancée nancy sinatra célibataire
tu recherches quoi bayrou une brune
benayad il valérie benaïm ou non voilà
c'est le valais rêver demetric bennett
balle un succès en ce moment sans
rigoler à lait vendu parce qu'elle est
très belle et elle est de plus en plus
belle c'est un truc mais n'a même plus
les années passent j'en parlais ce
week-end avec des copains oui il ya des
copains mois qui serait fortement
intéressé qu'aux jeunes de thé moche
autant là
non
allez on y va
il a fait parler sur qui thibault il ya
attention il ya des passionnés mais ça
yaya yale console une nouvelle console
de jeux gagnés grâce à micromania zinc
alors bon je vais dire match in guinea
allez c'est pas une minute
[Applaudissements]
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la défense yoplait
gâchis tout l'enlever
[Applaudissements]
c'est venu faire la console de salon
malheureusement mais cette offre un très
beau cadeau je vais t'offrir un truc
dont je t'offre un très beau cadeau
t'inquiète pas je m'occupe de toi
d'accord mon chéri d'accord bas mais
basta dit à venir nous voir voilà je
t'invite à venir soient d'accord